Let's do one more fairly
involved example of adding, or
in this case actually
subtracting rational
expressions.
Let's say I have 4 over
9x squared minus 49.
And from that I want to
subtract-- maybe I'll do this
in different color-- I want to
subtract 1 over 3x squared
plus 5x, minus 28.
So just like we saw in the last
video, we want to find
the least common multiple of
these two expressions.
And the way to figure out that
is to factor these two things.
Now this first expression,
you might recognize, is a
difference of squares.
This is 3x squared
minus 7 squared.
So we can rewrite it as 4 over
3x-- well, let me write it
this way-- 3x plus 7,
times 3x minus 7.
3x squared is 9x squared.
7 squared is 49.
Difference of squares.
And from that we're going to
subtract this thing over here.
Let's see how we can
factor that out.
Well, once again, this has a
non-1 coefficient here, so you
can always use the Pythagorean
theorem, but that actually
gets messy if you actually just
want to factor as opposed
to getting roots.
So the best thing here
is to do grouping.
So let me factor it over here.
I need to find two numbers.
Let me just write
it over here.
So we have 3x-- let
me write it.
I want to write it someplace
where I can-- well, actually
I'll write it here.
So I have 3x squared
plus 5x, minus 28.
I need to find two numbers that
when I multiply them I
get 3 times negative 28.
So it's negative 60 and negative
24, that's negative
84, if I multiply those
two numbers.
And a plus b should
be equal to 5.
So what numbers?
Well, it's 7 and 12.
Your times table.
7 times 12 is 84.
So if you make this a 12 and
you make this a negative 7,
then it works.
12 minus 7 is 5, 12 times
negative 7 is 84.
So I can rewrite this
as 3x squared.
I'll group the 12 with the 3,
because they have a common
factor of 3.
So plus 12x minus
7x, minus 28.
Once again, 7 and 28 have
a common factor, so
it's looking good.
And just to reiterate, all I
did is I rewrote this 5x as
12x minus 7x.
These are, obviously,
the same thing.
12x minus 7x is 5x.
But then we can group
them just like that.
If we factor out a 3x here, this
first expression is the
same thing as 3x
times x plus 4.
And in the second expression
over here-- I'll do it in red,
or in white I guess-- let's
factor out a negative 7.
So minus 7 times x plus 4.
And lucky for us, we have a
common factor is x plus 4, so
we can factor that out.
So if you factor out the x plus
4, you get x plus 4 times
3x minus 7.
So that's what this guy over
here will factor into.
So I can rewrite
it right here.
So this expression is the exact
same thing as 1 over--
well, I can write the 3x minus
7 first-- 3x minus 7
times x plus 4.
This and this is the exact
same statement.
So let's figure out what our
common denominator is here.
So our common denominator-- I'll
write it like that-- it
needs to have all of the factors
of this guy right
here, so it needs to
have a 3x plus 7.
It needs to have a 3x minus 7.
And also it has to have all of
the factors of this guy.
Well, it already has
a 3x minus 7, so
this is already done.
But it doesn't have an
x plus 4 in it yet.
So now I have to multiply
it by x plus 4.
So clearly, if you look at
this, this is clearly
divisible by this guy, because
it has all of its factors.
You could divide this out.
And it's clearly divisible
by this guy.
You have 3x minus 7
times x plus 4.
3x minus 7 times x plus 4.
So this is the least common
multiple of these two
expressions.
Now, how do we get-- so what
do we have to multiply this
guy by to have this as
the denominator?
Well, I just have to multiply
the numerator and the
denominator by x plus 4.
So if I multiply this guy-- let
me scroll to the left a
little bit-- by x plus
4 over x plus 4, my
denominator will work out.
And so my numerator will become
4 times x plus 4, which
is 4x plus 16.
That's this first
term over here.
And then what do I have to
multiply this guy by to have
the same denominator as this?
Well, I have a 3x minus
7 times x plus 4.
3x minus 7 times x plus 4.
I have to multiply
it by 3x plus 7.
So I also have to multiply the
numerator by 3x plus 7.
So this is 4x plus 16 minus 1
times 3x plus 7, or minus 3x
plus 7 is the same thing
as minus 3x minus 7.
I'm just distributing
the negative sign.
And then what is this going
to be equal to?
The numerator, we have a 4x
minus a 3x will just be an x.
And then we have a 16 minus
a 7, which is a 9.
And then the denominator, we,
of course, have all of this
stuff over here, which is 3x
plus 7, times 3x minus 7,
times x plus 4.
And we're done.